the 1999 film galaxy quest is a terrific
and clever sci-fi comedy that's both a
satire and a loving tribute to space
sci-fi
there's plenty for both kids and adults
to enjoy about the film but the
hilarious intergalactic romp includes a
lot of jokes and meta commentary that
only adults will appreciate
while galaxy quest is a lighthearted
comedy its sci-fi world is treated as
seriously as it would be in a legitimate
star trek movie
the design and production values are on
par with other big screen
space adventures of its day and similar
talent and methods were employed to make
it that way
the visual effects and starship models
were created by industrial light and
magic
the top shelf effects house that was
born from the production of star wars
the makeup effects for the villainous
series and his soldiers were headed up
by stan winston
the legendary artist behind the thing
according to never surrender a galaxy
quest documentary making the sci-fi
elements the straight man of the comedy
was a deliberate decision
in order for the film to work the sci-fi
stakes needed to be totally real with
the comedic elements stemming from the
human characters or the way the
thermians literally incorporated the
galaxy quest tv show into their culture
making a clear delineation between the
real dangers of space
and the very fake tv world to which the
actors are accustomed actually helped
heighten the comedy
it's the context of the creatures and
circumstances the characters encounter
that makes them funny
not those things themselves
galaxy quest centers around the strained
dynamic between star jason nesmoth and
the rest of the cast of the galaxy quest
tv series which is similar to the
decades-long conflict between star trek
william shatner and his co-stars
much of the cast of star trek have
openly criticized or expressed dislike
for shatner
while shatner expressed puzzlement as to
why castmates leonard nimoy and george
takei
have complained that shatner would use
his power as number one on the show's
call sheet to steal
other actors lines or close-ups or to
try and hog press attention
like nsmith shatner doesn't seem to find
anything wrong with his own behavior but
while jason seems to harbor no ill
will towards the crew shatner is
famously defensive and publicly casts
decay as
irrational however the rest of the trek
cast has enjoyed a very close
family-like relationship much like the
one seen in galaxy quest
in the film gwen demarco says you see we
work together
or not at all this mirrors leonard
nimoy's refusal to participate in star
trek the animated series unless michelle
nichols and george takei were also hired
nichols and walter koenig were best lady
and best man
at takei's wedding to which shatner was
not invited shatner also did not attend
leonard nimoy's funeral due to a
scheduling conflict but says he
doesn't think he'd have been welcome
anyway in galaxy quest alan rickman's
character alexander
dain is a serious actor who feels that
his career has been destroyed by his
years playing the alien dr lazarus
dane's plight is far from uncommon as
actors who do sci-fi television often
find themselves shoehorned into similar
roles
but alexander's frustration seemed to be
particularly inspired by the life of one
particular trek cast member
leonard nimoy while nimoy might not have
expressed the levels of resentment that
dane does in the film
he did struggle with being so closely
identified with spock
nimoy found that it made it hard to
further his career as an actor
leading to his moving behind the camera
as a director
this struggle became exaggerated in the
public eye when his first autobiography
was published under the controversial
title i am not spock
which created a misconception that nimoy
disliked the role
and the place it created for him in pop
culture nimoy sought to correct this
perception by naming his 1995 follow-up
i am spock while dane's story is more
dramatic he
also makes peace with his iconic role by
the end of the film
one of galaxy quest's running gags is
the quiet calm of fred quan who doesn't
seem to respond appropriately to any of
the peril and weirdness that happens
throughout the film
it's easy to read the chill frequently
snacking fred as being in a
marijuana-fueled haze throughout the
action
this is actually deliberate and is a
holdover from the original intent that
galaxy quest be a more adult-oriented
comedy
tony shalhoub was originally up for the
part of gai which ultimately went to sam
rockwell but director dean pariso
invited shaloub to play fred kwan
instead
shalub initially declined as he felt an
asian actor should play an asian
character but the two determined that
fred himself is actually a non-asian
actor playing the asian character
tech sergeant chen this development
reminded shaloub of an unconfirmed rumor
that actor david carradine while
portraying the whitewashed role of kwai
chang kane on the 1970's tv series kung
fu
smoked weed constantly on set shalub and
pariso invented a backstory for fred
that he had done the same thing
and then ended up becoming a burnout and
the part was totally
rewritten with that in mind very little
of this made it into the final film with
many of chalub's stoner gags being cut
and the only acknowledgement of fred's
faking his ethnicity being a passing
reference to kwon not
really being his last name early in
galaxy quest we learned that jason
nezmuth has been hired to make
a personal appearance by teenage fan
brandon and his friends
jason explains it by saying it's not a
big deal these guys put a little set in
their basement i'm there about an hour
however despite jason's downplaying
consider how expensive it must be
to book jason nesmoth for a one hour
appearance
yes he's an out of work actor but he's
still got a nice house in the hollywood
hills and
is apparently in enough demand to
warrant a three-day convention dedicated
to his long-cancelled tv series
serious acting work may have dried up
but there's no shortage of people
looking to pay money for nsmith's
attention
in 2021 a 10-minute live zoom call with
star trek actor jonathan frakes
cost 750 getting galaxy quest's
lead actor to play his most famous role
for an hour in their basement could not
be cheap
even if you skimp on the limo after
receiving and misinterpreting earth's
television broadcast
the thermians remodeled their entire
society and technology after galaxy
quest
in excruciating detail while earth's tv
signals really do escape our planet and
travel into space
when you do the math the thermian's
galaxy quest makeover must have been
extremely rapid
let's be generous and imagine that
thermia is a very close neighbor to
earth
the closest star to our sun proxima
centauri actually does have a planet
proxima b
proxima is about 4.2 light years from
earth so it would take a television
broadcast 4.2 years to reach there
galaxy quest aired roughly between 1977
and 1982 so its first episodes would
have reached proxima beginning in the
early 1980s
the film is set less than two decades
later in 1999 or 2000.
if the thermians lived on proxima b that
doesn't leave very long to reconstruct
their culture develop their technology
to mimic that of galaxy quest and then
travel all the way to earth and if you
consider thermia
is probably much farther away that gives
them even less time to work with
it's obvious when watching the film that
thermians are scientifically brilliant
but factoring for real-life physical
constraints their genius is actually
understated
when we last see the thermians in galaxy
quest math czar
is commanding the nsea protector with a
newfound confidence and the ship
warps off into space after dropping off
the television cast back on earth
but as light and positive as this scene
is framed and as cheerful as the
thermians seem their future is actually
looking pretty bleak
as teb reveals earlier in the film the
crew of the protector
is all that remains of the thermian
civilization
after the rest were exterminated by
general serris
aside from the protector's starport
mathazar and his crew have no home to
which to return
being forced to wander the stars
indefinitely in their starship is
definitely
preferable to extermination but it will
still be a struggle
plus the crew will also eventually have
to cope with the recent demise of their
homeworld
the film's finale sees the human cast of
galaxy quest crash landing the command
deck of the nsea protector into the main
stage of the galaxy quest convention
the fans inside the hall seem to think
this is just an elaborate stunt but the
moment they leave the building they're
going to notice that there's a path of
destruction
running through the parking lot and a
gaping hole in the side of the building
some other cars have been destroyed
people are going to put two and two
together
the very last minute of the film reveals
that following the events of the film
galaxy quest returns to television for
new episodes
but somewhere in between there would
have to have been
some consequences of an alien spaceship
crash landing into a california civic
center
did the u.s government get involved was
there a cover-up
how did they keep people from talking
one possible explanation could be that
in exchange for their silence a shady
government entity
offered the hundreds of witnesses at the
convention the one thing they wanted
most
the return of the cheesy tv show they
love
part of what keeps the stakes of galaxy
quest pretty light is that there are no
negative consequences of the actors
being abducted by aliens near the start
of the film
when gwen and the crew tell jason that
they want to go home
jason pushes back by implying there's
nothing waiting for them there
say the word we'll go home pay our bills
feed our fish
fall asleep in front of the tv and miss
out on all of
this this is a sad realization about the
characters but it's very convenient for
the story
none of the cast has partners waiting
for them to come home or kids who need
to be picked up from soccer practice
no one tries to get in touch with anyone
back on earth at least not until jason
needs to reach brandon for some tech
support
the galaxy quest cast is evidently the
only family any of them have which
ratchets up the importance of their
relationship
and makes their ability to get along the
highest personal stakes for these
characters
galaxy quest is a breezy comedy
adventure but it's also a story about
how investing emotionally in a fictional
world can enrich your real life
the thermians found peace and purpose in
literally believing in
idolized heroes the show's fans too
clearly find a lot of enrichment in
knowingly participating in the fantasy
of galaxy quest
both groups provide a lot of unwitting
humor in the film but that humor is
mostly good-natured
while both the human and
extraterrestrial fans of the galaxy
quest tv series have
already learned the importance of
fantasy before the start of the story
it takes the main characters of the
series a little longer over the course
of the film we see the jaded and
exhausted actors
slowly become the heroes that their fans
always believed them to be
jason only truly becomes the commander
once he puts his trust in his friends
and comes clean to the thermians about
his deception alexander finds dr lazarus
within himself by understanding what he
means to quellic who sees him as a
surrogate father
fred tommy and guy each find a new
confidence by rising to the standards of
their characters and beyond the cast
grows through the belief of people who
look at them
and see the people they'd like to be
even if they weren't real to begin with
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one